bienvenidos ahora veremos más problemas
sobre ventaja mecánica y en este vídeo
nos enfocaremos en poleras que son otro
tipo de máquinas simples ya hemos hecho
problemas con poleas en anterioridad en
otros vídeos pero ahora podremos
entender cuál es la ventaja mecánica
inherente a estas máquinas vamos a
comenzar con una polea simple imaginemos
que tengo
este es mi techo
y de aquí tengo colgada
una polea que puede girar sobre sí
millas
tengo aquí
un peso
de unos 10 minutos
y tengo una cuerda
bueno dónde está pasa aquí por la polea
tiene está sujeta del peso
y de esta cuerda
está cayendo de este lado
bueno en cualquier situación en la que
se involucre una polea y no sé si los
libros de texto lo expliquen así pero
esa es la manera en que yo lo entiendo
para no tener que memorizar fórmulas yo
pienso en que es lo que sucede con las
longitudes de la cuerda o cuál es la
distancia total a la que el objeto que
tratemos de mover se desplaza bueno si
conoce la distancia a la que viaja y lo
comparan con la distancia que ustedes
tuvieron que jalar si comparan la
distancia de lo que sus objetos subió y
lo comparan con la distancia que ustedes
tuvieron que jalar de esta cuerda hacia
abajo
entonces van a conocer la ventaja
mecánica si ya tomar esta cuerda en este
punto y la jalar hacia abajo unos tres
metros
unos tres metros o cualquier distancia
arbitraria que ocurra en este otro lado
bueno este peso va a subir exactamente
la misma distancia así que la distancia
de la cuerda de la cuerda que él ojalá
que yo jaló hacia abajo será equivalente
a la distancia que el objeto sube de
este otro lado y como sabemos que el
trabajo de entrada tiene que ser igual
al trabajo de salida sabemos que la
fuerza con la que estoy jalando hacia
abajo tendrá que ser la misma la fuerza
o la atención que la cuerda tendrá en
este otro lado ya habíamos mencionado
antes que en una polea la atención en la
cuerda es constante al menos en cuando
el material de la cuerda es el mismo si
cambia de material puede haber
diferencias pero si el material de la
cuerda es el mismo la atención en toda
la cuerda va a ser igual
entonces pues igual pareciera que no es
una máquina interesante ya que voy a
jalar hacia abajo con una fuerza de 10
newtons y esto va a elevar esta fuerza
de 10 minutos así que la ventaja
mecánica de una polea sencilla como ésta
va a ser igual a 1 no sé si no hay
ventaja ventaja mecánica real aunque
esto sigue siendo útil pues quizás me
sea más fácil jalar hacia abajo la
cuerda que cargará este peso y
levantarlo a la altura que yo quiero o
quizá yo no pueda alcanzar esta altura
este por mis medios y con la polea puedo
levantar esto y ya después por
posicionarlo en la altura que yo quiero
pero bueno bueno aunque eso tiene su
utilidad su ventaja mecánica va a ser
igual a 1 vamos a ver si podemos
encontrar una situación mecánica en la
que la ventaja de la polea sea mayor a 1
ahora vamos a tener la misma polea
colgada del techo
y además vamos a tener otra polea aquí
abajo podemos imaginar que está pegada
hacia la pared del fondo
y vamos a tener
a nuestro peso
aquí de este lado abajo de esta pole
y vamos a tener una cuerda que va a
bajar de este lado
rodea la primera pole al rodea la
segunda pole ahí va a estar
atada
al techo y esta cuerda
también va a estar atada a este peso
si yo tomaré esta cuerda y la jalar a
digamos que dos metros hacia abajo
suponiendo que la tomo hacia acá eñ la
jaló dos metros
hacia acá pues qué va a ocurrir con una
cuerda bueno estoy hablando esta parte
dos metros hacia acá y obviamente como
esta cuerda es este pues una pieza
completa esta parte de aquí también se
va a desplazar dos metros hacia la
derecha si esta parte se desplaza dos
metros y yo quiero ver cuánto se
desplaza esta parte de este lado de la
amb polea y esta parte voy a tener que
ésta se va a desplazar
un metro y esta parte se va a desplazar
también un metro para que sean
equivalentes a los dos metros que estoy
jalando aquí abajo
entonces bueno qué es lo que va a pasar
estoy jalando toda la cuerda se va a
recorrer para acá y el peso este peso se
va a mover hacia acá
un metro entonces cuál es el trabajo que
estoy realizando
bueno tenemos que el trabajo de entrada
va a ser igual al trabajo de salida y
sabemos cuál es el trabajo de salida que
es la fuerza que este sistema usa para
levantar este peso digamos que es igual
nuestro nuestro peso es de 10 newtons
entonces mi trabajo de salida
va a ser igual
este peso o la fuerza 10 newtons por la
distancia que lo moví que es igual a un
metro y nos queda que el trabajo de
salida es igual a 10 jules y este debe
ser también el trabajo que yo estoy
usando en la entrada por lo que mi
trabajo de entrada también va a ser
igual a 10 hills
y bueno conozco la distancia que lo
desplace aquí al inicio y ahora quiero
conocer cuál es la fuerza entonces
tenemos que el trabajo es igual a la
fuerza por la distancia
y en este caso mi distancia fue de 2
metros mi trabajo es de 10 entonces mi
fuerza es igual a mi trabajo de entrada
entre la distancia inicial
y es igual a 10 jus entre la distancia
inicial fueron 2 metros por lo que mi
fuerza va a ser igual a 5 newtons mi
fuerza inicial mi fuerza de entrada
y bueno eso tiene sentido porque este
bueno estoy ocupando el doble de
distancia para mover la mitad de esta
distancia de este sistema cuál va a ser
la ventaja mecánica
sabemos que la ventaja mecánica o emea
en inglés mecánica las bandas va a ser
igual a la fuerza de salida entre la
fuerza de entrada la fuerza de salida
queremos que era levantar
estos 10 newtons y mi fuerza de salida
resultaron cinco newtons por lo que la
ventaja mecánica de este sistema es
igual a 2 duplica y como encimó esto
tiene sentido porque bueno ocupe la
mitad de fuerza para levantar esto pero
tuve que desplazar la cuerda el doble de
la distancia de lo que se desplazó este
objeto al final
bueno vamos a hacer otro problema
sencillo
vamos a decir que tengo una cuña
por cierto que una cuña se le considera
una máquina y este es algo que me costó
trabajo comprender
o imaginas este elemento como una
máquina porque es una máquina porque la
una es una máquina pues porque nos da
una ventaja mecánica
suponiendo tengo yo esta cuña aquí hay
un ángulo de 30 grados
aquí tengo una distancia que voy a
llamar distancia d
y aquí bueno no sé cuál es y cuál va a
ser esta distancia pero si yo quisiera
saber esta distancia de este otro lado
bueno tengo el cateto opuesto entre el
cateto perdón chica tetro puesto de
entre la hipotenusa entonces voy a usar
el seno de 30 grados y el seno de 30
grados es un medio si tienen alguna duda
con respecto a esto los invito a que
revisión en los vídeos de trigonometría
digo no metría entonces esta distancia
va a ser la mitad de mi hipotenusa y
bueno
esta es mi cuña y vamos a decir que yo
aquí tengo en este punto tengo una caja
y esta caja la quiero empujar o que le
tengo que aplicar una fuerza para
empujar esta caja toda esta distancia
hasta este punto
aquí quiero llevar esta caja o este peso
cuál va a ser la ventaja mecánica de
este sistema cuando la caja está aquí
arriba yo sé que tiene una energía
potencial y esa energía potencial va a
ser el peso de la caja por su altura
digamos que esta caja pesa unos 10
newtons
y bueno esta es la altura a la que se
encuentra entonces en este punto la
energía potencial
va a ser igual a la fuerza por la
distancia de las fuerzas son 10 newtons
y la distancia es
un medio de d
si yo hago esta multiplicación entonces
la energía potencial va a ser igual a 5
una distancia
con unidad de luz porque es energía y
este va a ser también el trabajo de
entrada ya sabemos que el trabajo de
entrada es igual al trabajo de salida
así que en este punto mi trabajo también
es de 5 de jules
y cuál va a ser la fuerza que tuve
quiero aplicar esta fuerza cuál es la
fuerza que tuviera que aplicar para
llevar esta caja de este punto acá en
este sistema
bueno entonces tenemos que conozco mi
trabajo de entrada no escribir se ha
dado mi trabajo de entrada va a ser
igual a la fuerza por la distancia en mi
trabajo de entrada es igual a mi trabajo
de salida que es
5 por de news es igual a mi fuerza de
entrada que es lo que quiero saber por
la distancia que es esta distancia
despejo mi fuerza mi fuerza de entrada
va a ser igual a
5 de entre de estas unidades se van y me
queda que mi fuerza de entrada va a ser
igual a 5 minutos
así que use 5 minutos de fuerza para
levantar o llevar este peso de 10
minutos hasta este punto y la energía
mecánica pero la ventaja mecánica en
este va a ser
la ventaja mecánica es igual a la fuerza
de salida entre la fuerza de entrada que
es igual a 10 entre 5 y tenemos que
nuestra ventaja mecánica en este sistema
es igual a 2